salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
aujourd'hui nous sommes
à et on a trouvé un pont super sympa
regardez c'est l'endroit idéal pour
pêcher àément bon il y a un petit peu de
fer au bord ça a sûrement déjà été fait
par d'utres pêcheursément et peut-être
même par des abonnés ditesnous si c'est
vous en commentaire maintenant l'intro
c'est terminé ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va pêcher àé tu es prêt
c'est allez j'ai quelque
chose allez super oh le couteau il est
beau oua oh mais super ah benah oui en
plus mais alors là c'est un super
premier lancé ça ouais munition bien
jouer alors ça c'était un outil c'est
quoi le deuxième nom qui donne au Beig
quand tu es en général des gens une ou
une
ou et oui d'ailleurs on l'a pas dit tout
à l'heure mais c'est le fameux pruneo
d'agin là j'ai pas mal de choses prof
qu'il en
reste
wou qu'est-ce
donc on dirait un morceau de wou un
cylindre de voiture qui a été coupé en
deux on dirait pourtant c'est censé être
très costaud ça bien sûr rasta toujours
là en pleine forme voyez il a Harn
maintenant d'habitude il était au
collier et là il a l'air plus
intelligent comme ça rasta tu montres
c'est
bien ah une [__] sympa [__]
douce [__] d'eau douce ok une
canette y voir ce qu'on trouve sur ce
pont allez j'ai quelque
chose
wouh bah ouais franchement
ok donc ça c'est un
marteau sans
manche ça c'est une pince à cliquer
peut-être
cliquer après qu'est-ce qu'on a bon rien
de très intéressant ouais on a des
choses
W qu'est-ce que
c'est ah c'est un oiseau ouais un jouet
pour en un jouet oiseau et il bouge
attends c'est
original c'est
drôle si vous savez ce que c'est en
commentaire
ah et ben un boulon ah oui un franc un
demi franc alors est-ce qu'on voit
l'année 50 centimes de franc Fran ah oui
50 centimes de francs pardon c'est pas
mon époque
ça
ah j'arrive pas à lire l'année
là alors ça dit quoi de ton côté ouais
je vois c'est quoi tournev tournev bien
joué pour l'instant reste très bien
là-haut posé sur son petit rocher
ah
W sympa ça on dirait un peu un bracelet
ah je vais sortir là c'est
cuivré regardez si on dirait le morceau
d'un bracelet cassé ou quelque chose
comme ça sympa pas mal alors des fois il
faut bien regarder les MS parce que même
quand on pense qu'on a rien du tout
en cherchant bien là par exemple on a
une
ogive regarde comment elle se met droite
avec les mains travers hop donc bien
sympa on va aller voir ce côté du pont
maintenant où il y a
Baptiste en espérant faire mieux pour
l'instant
c'est mettre sur la dalle ici ah ça a dû
être fait ici encore une fois mais
bon on ne sait jamais en tout cas c'est
très sympa le coin là j'ai eu quelques
trucs
aussi oui effectivement il y a des
choses ça c'est une clé moi aussi
regarde une
clé totalement
morte et ensuite le cousé les sardines à
l'huile de tournesol
écoute qu' soit
vide il y a un
os
att il a failli tomber dans l' oh j'ai
quelque chose de assez
lourd
W est
magnifique c'est quoi ça mais arrête il
a quelque chose dedans c'est une boî
mais c'est trop bien ça quoi attends
mais rien que les motifs sur la boîte
c'est quoi il sont beau il sont pas AB
du tout mais ça fait Renaissance ok mais
arrêteuse pas écoute c'est trop bien
peut-être c'est une boîte de bonbon et
on par juste en ESS de ouvrir par là
mais vas-y
doucement je pour pas faut peut-être la
nettoyer un peu avant mais elle est
encore hermétique il y a pas d'autre
dedans ouais c'est un truc de dingue
trop stylé mais des bonbons pe que c'est
juste un truc en mode ancien mais c'est
des bonbons magnifique ça magnifique
bravo c'est incroyable
tu attends mais j'ai peur fait une super
non mais tu sais qu'il y avait un motif
derrière aussi ben on va le nettoyer
doucement mais comment ça peut être
encore hermétique c'est un truc de
dingue ouais bien fermé ouais c'est de
la qualité attends il y a quelque chose
dedans en plus faudra la nettoyer comme
il faut elle je sais pas si on pourra
l'ouvrir hein on va
voir allez je me suis décalé un peu plus
loin que le pon on va voir ce que
j'arrive à trouver ici allez fais-nous
un beau lancer
trop je sais pas si c'est les alges ou
pas mais j'ai quelques trucs je pense
alors
une
pièce waouh c'est 1 franc ça il me
semble ou 2 francs 1 franc je essayer de
voir l'année c'est difficile à
lire on verra plus tard
oh un
couteau
cassé alors là je viens de remonter cet
aiment et regarde un peu de tout on a
une lame de couteau ah ouais la même que
tu as faite hier ouais un peu même état
en plus et une pile quand même ah bravo
bien ancienne donc c'est une belle
dépollution et ça j'ai cru que c'était
un chargeur mais non ça n'est pas là il
y a un gros truc où je suis là regarde
tu vois les bulles
wou c'est quoi
ça regarde un piquet bizarre il est
stylé boule au bout une de flèche et un
anneau à l'arrière je crois c'est un
piquet de péniche non non c'est pas un
anneau je pense pas
in ça c'est bien
tu comire pour moi piqu'est que tu n
sors de beau
là de Ch CAN est encore une
fois
regarde
cceau d'ri et là regarde trouvé
on va la filmer au téléphone pour focus
25 centimes d'ancien franc ou
REC la plus ancienne pièce qu'on a
pché d'anci
fr03 bien jou VI B
découverte vélo
icine
gastrique
ah oui ça été fait mais il en reste ça
pas
é oh regarde W comme elle est belle mais
what elle est pasenté je crois
attends elle est toute neuve je Meur non
c'est italien c'est du lire 1976 regarde
elle est comme neuve c'est du nickel
regardezine
les pièces italiennes r très bien ah
ouais là c'est incroyable
Z regarde il viennent de la fabriquer
même pas une
rayure ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ah
tuas une pièce quand même ù ça ah oui
bah c'est M que rien 2 centimes d'euros
il y a sûrement eu un accident avec une
pénich qui transporté des clous et des
coffres forts des clous et des coffres
forts qui venaient d'Italie d'ailleurs
tu connais l'expression être dans les
clous V c'est oh là
là et ben on est typiquement dans les
clous ok une clé à pipe là elle est
morte bon ben voilà donc là on a changé
de spot on est un peu plus loin sous une
passerelle piétonne mais il devrait y
avoir des choses parce qu'on est à côté
d'un stade d'une école je pense donc
c'est parti on va voir premier lancé
avec notre aimant barbarien de chez
Maison de la détection Baptiste
qu'est-ce que tu nous conseille pour
commencer la pêche à Barbarian c'est un
aimant qui a 1600 kg de force donc 1600
kg c'est énorme c'est le plus gros du
marché il faut savoir qu'il y a
différentes gammes d'aimant 360 et en
général on conseille le terror pour
démarrer dans tous les cas vous avez le
choix vous avez le site qui est en
description et vous avez le code promo
pêcheur de trésor qui offre 5 % sur
toute la boutique allez c'est parti hop
là j'aimerais bien faire un vélo tout
neuf là ah j'ai quelque chose là
enfin bon oh oui un poid d'haltère
Baptiste tu vas être content toi qui
aime bien faire le sport 2,50 le kil et
ben il y a 1
kg tu as gagné 2,50 € c'est bon
ça j'ai eu aussi une vieille clé
bon pas des plus jolis mais bon c'est
sympa une bague
peut-être j'ai trouvé une bague
Baptiste ouis
elle est très
moche mais bon ça reste une bague quand
tuas quelque chose de gros juste au bord
alors je l'en vois derrière
ou
tu d
non là je suis sur ton éman je pense non
non je pense pas ah non c'est du béton
arméter ah ouais ouais tu es sûr ouais
il est vers le haut il est droit ok bah
allez c'est quoi le nom du clubviron à
jeuner allez l'aviron à
jeuner e super ci beaucoup scooter là je
va chercher attendsève unu je pense
ça je reste comme ça
moi donc là on a repéré ce qui semble
être un scooter on va essayer de
l'accrocherve le grappin juste pour le
rapprocher un peu et l'attacher parce
que le mieux c'est l'attacher comme les
scooter c'est pas trop aé autant
directementattacher j'ai sur la rou
arrière je vais essayer de resouever un
peu tu vasouir
grapiner
ok ah il est beau ouais tu V l'attacher
ouais mais du coup on a pas de cord en
plus là
il a l'air sympa en vrai je pense c'est
pas un truc trop lambda et en même temps
pas trop lourd h ah si on arrive à deux
bon on va se casser le dos
non ah vou peut-être on peut faut
voir ah rasta tu viens nous aider
il fait les bêtises je sais pas si on y
arrive à deux par contre on va
essayer c'est quand même chauffé un peu
le
[Musique]
dos chaud pour
tirer vas-y il est chaud
B tu viens avec
moi moi je vais rester devant pourever
derrière je pense faudra sa pour qu'il
passe la mche on va tirer à deux sur la
corde ouais et après quand on va essayer
juste de le de le monter une fois qu'il
a monté ça ce sera bon allez 1 2
continuez là c'est déjà pas mal là là
faudrait peut-être attraperer l'arrière
non attraper le guidon c'est quoi le MIN
attends tenz comme ça le guidon moi
j'attrape le guidon tu vas ouais attends
je peux je peux tirer ça déjà non tu CIS
que tu peux
attends
estce tu arrives on a besoin d'aide
attends il y a quelqu'un qui arrive
attends un peu attends un peu attends
attends un peu il arrive sur la corde tu
veou ouais vous pouvez tirer sur la
corde ouais ça fait
maintenir ah il veut pas passer
par-dessus faut le faire attends
guidon c que ça fait longtemps qu'il est
là
ouais V la vase quelques mois quand
même là ça
bloquemter le guidon on Ti 3 1 2
3 est
presque c'est limite ouais [__] il
faudrait une autre personne monsieur du
club qui arrive attention qu' retombe
pas [__] il va retomber là non
nickel c'est le plastique qui casse
de la V dans la bouche a quel goût on va
avoir de l'IDE mais c'est vrai que à
deux c'est
impossible comme ça faut le trailler et
tout mais c'est galère allez allez on
est prêt allez allez go 1 2 3 1 2
allez
ah on est presque allez allez
ouais on est presque ou bien
joué
bravo il estand
Mme bravo pour vre merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup pêcheur de trésor sympa oua
merci beaucoup pour le coup de main en
tout
cas bon il y a pas de plaque on dirait
hein il y a rien dedans
euh non il y a rien
ok bah ouais entre quelques semaines et
quelques mois il a eu le temps de
rouiller quand même sympa ou ouais
nickel qu'est-ce qu'on va faaire de ce
scooter il y a pas la plaque donc on va
juste appeler la mairie pour qu'il
récupère on va le mettre à côté des
poubelles en tout cas un grand merci aux
abonnés qui nous ont aidé et aux non
abonnés qui nous ont aidé parce que
c'est vrai que les gens nous aident même
quand ils nous connaissent pas donc ça
ça fait très plaisir et pour ceux qui
savent le modèle aussi diteslenous en
commentaire il rou bien encore ouais
attends on va faire quelques photos
faire un tour surtout faire un tour avec
pour ceux qui sen rappelle il y a tout
juste 3 ans et demi on était à peu près
sur le même type de scène et avec
Quentin on avait remonté notre premier
scooter qu'on était en train de
[Musique]
tester c'était une de nos vidéos qui
avait le plus marché à l'époque et j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour vous remercier
on naurait jamais pensé à être près de
390000 3 ans et demi après la vidéo est
en description par contre pas un seul
une seule trace d'essence quand l' remé
je pense que réservoir pas pas perc on
peut regarder d'ailleurs de toute façon
en reste est-ce qu'on va le sifonner lui
aussi dernière fois avit Sion cette
fois- ça pas percer donc je pense que
soit ils sont en pan d'essence c'est
pour ça qu'il l' jeté oh il est
plein ah ouais ça serait con de jeter on
a rien pour siffonner là c'est de la
vraie essence il est pas percé on la
poire ass je crois c'est vrai ouais on
peut tenter ah mais c'est Gal de la d'cd
non elle est à l'avant ah ouais on tente
on a pas de bidon on a la bouteille à
l'arrière de coca ouais vasy allez go on
teste j'ai aperçu déjà quelque chose et
oui antivol antivol de vélo alors les
antivoles comme ça franchement presque
avec les dents ah non il éta coupé ouais
oui ouais ouaisoua il est comme ça c'est
dommage hein mais ouais c'est nul mais
tu pas ça ça sert à
rien oh mais j'ai une chaîne aussi ah
ouais un collier plaqué ça doê du plaqué
c'est du il reste du cuivre
ok elle est cassée un peu mais je peux
la mettre quand même je pense oh ah
c'est
horrible
d'accordouche filtre à gasoile non ouais
à huile ou gasoile et ça avec un
crochet je sais pas
trop qu'est-ce que c'est attention waou
un amortisseur de vélo ouais
ça ah c'est une imprimante je
pense ou une machine à écrire peut-être
mais je dirais imprimante
OK et ouais l'amortisseur de scooter ou
de
[Musique]
mobil
allez oh oui il y a des trucs le
couteau Coutau qutin mais il est beau tu
peux t' servirel en vrai celu-là il est
très bon hein
cel un couteau on fait pas mal
aujourd'hui les couteaux ah j'ai quelque
chose
oh
euh non non je crois que c'est une
plaque une plaque de cuisson je crois
alle
c'est bon je
l'ai ouais lecteur DVD cassette Sony
ok ben ça en moins dans l'eau he ça
bonne dépollution
ouais ça fait plus cassette que DVD non
compact si disque disque c'est disque
ouais disque e il y a des choses là il y
a plein de choses des choses qu'est-ce
que tu sors de beau allez je fais une
remontée en direct je la dédie au au
jeunes de l'aviron là on va voir ce
qu'on a à eu ouais oh non m'enda mieux
pas tant que ça une serrure c'est une
serrure ça ouais c'est tout non c'est
tout carré ah il y a une pièce quand
même 1
centime ça paye le lancer ça paye le
lancer ils sont pas chers mes lancer
alors non
toute la
journée W une
montre une montre de collection
elle est
horrible c'est du ok en plus elle a pris
cher bon ça reste une montre je suis
content et là regardez je viens de
retrouver une relique du passé un hand
spinner alors est-ce qu'il fonctionne
non il est rouillé il ne fonctionne
plusens je te l'offre il le Ve
pas qu'est-ce qu'on
a ah j'ai déjà vu ça j'ai déjà vu ça
mais je sais plus trop ce que
c'est W j'ai plein de
choses encore un
Caden Caden pas
cassé deux piles donc ça c'est
intéressant bonne dépollution plus ce
sachet plastique et ça c'est un
porte-clé intéressant Peugeot
ouais c'est un peu collector
peut-être ça vient d'un garage PE
sympa les les plus forts reconnaîtront
avec le logo mais ça c'est l'ancien
c'est l'ancien il un moment celui il me
semble de logo Peugeot ce lion là petit
souvenir d'agin faute de ramener des
pruneaux on va ramener des porteclés
ok encore une pile allez j'ai pas mal de
trucs je pense encore une fois ah quo
que non pas tant que
ça celui qui a la meilleure
découverteap ah ben voilà un autre
couteau en aussi bon état que l'ancien
franchement ou je
prends je prends elle est sympa la
couleur je croyais que c'était la vase
mais c'est la vraie couleur il est un
peu Abé au bout dommage
ok une paire de ciseaux et encore une
pile c'est incroyable nombre de pil qu'
ici quand un travaille un objet
là allez vas-y
c'est pas si lourd mais c'est dans la
base on va
voir la milieu
presque oh oh ça c'est de la suspension
ouais suspension de de moto hein bah
ouais elle est belle elle est pas très
vieille si elle marche ouais marche
vas-yement qui
gêne
c'est bon comme neu
ouais mais pas
que c'est ça c'est un arrière de scooter
ou de vélo non
oua porte
bagage qu'est-ce que j'ai encore oh ah
c'est le reste de
l'imprimante la
suite sachet
vide
allez oui un
tabouré et une fourchette après les
couteaux la
fourchette ce soir tu manges
avec alors tu as des trucs bah plus
grand chose ça commence à être propre
ouais bah on a fait toute cette portion
on sait qu'elle est
clean si vous voulez une partie 2 àin
ditesle nous en commentaire partie 3
même Quentin partie 3
hop h la salade un truc un truc
qu'est-ce que c'est un un couteau suisse
ah nonir de vélo je crois ah d'accordre
chose il un
pochon un pochonimenté bah ouais is
c'est
vrai c'est une vis on l'ouvre ouvrele
vous êtes prêt pour la dinguerie dans le
pochon des bijou
peut-être c'est des écrous un écrou et
une vis sûr il y a eu un accident le
cche de ma montre s ouvert donc là vous
pouvez apercevoir que c'est de la très
bonne horlogerie du style Rolex que du
mécanisme à mouvement perpétuel voilà en
vrai l'intérieur il pas si si habîé que
ça ah non contre il bien
à
c'est fa btiste tu Paris sur quoi alors
franchement on a eu plein de pronostic
on a dit des dents mais ça sonne pas
comme des dents non on a dit des bijoux
mais ça paraît comme tant plein de
petites choses moi je reste sur des
dents moi vims a dit peut-être des
munitions de des PL ou des munitions de
fusil petites Bill peut-être possible
moi je dis que c'est une chaî en or moi
je dis que c'est des dents moi aussi je
reste sur des dents de gamin comme
jade ça commence à se nettoyer petit à
[Musique]
petit
oh c'est des c'est quoi des perles des
perles c'est juste pour enfiler des
perles rien de fou par contre la boîte
elle est terrible elle est en argent
ouais elle est plaquegent
non des perles c'est pour faire un petit
bracelet un collier mais en quoi des
vrai on fait appel à vous pour
l'expertice de ces pierres alors selon
nous ça vient certainement d'un
chapelier puisqueen effet on peut voir
la présence de graines voilà c'est la
fin de cette vidéo de pêche àément vous
voyez le coffre est bien rempli bon on a
triché un peu une pas qu'un là mais
c'est déjà pas mal on a du bon poids
ouais et on se dit à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de
pêche àément bonjour